Speaker 1: This weekend was really one of the most
consequential and busy weekends of news for a long
time, we had the continued Russian invasion of
Ukraine. Vladimir Putin has coyly floated the idea
that maybe nukes are in the picture by raising the
readiness level of the nuclear deterrent systems.
We'll talk about that. And meanwhile, Republicans
held their CPAC convention in Orlando, Florida, as
if we needed a reminder of the sick and disgusting
nature of the right wing movement. And in addition
to this, there was a competing convention AfPak
adjacent to CPAC geographically, which was openly
white nationalist. Marjorie Taylor Greene spoke
there. Mitt Romney has called out more quote moron
Republicans like Marjorie Taylor Greene. And so we
have so much to cover and let's get right into it,
starting with Russia. The first thing I
want to just make sure everybody understands
is when no one news is breaking so quickly on
something like Ukraine, Russia. And number two,
when some of the things that break as news later
turn out to have been incorrectly reported. So,
for example, videos that come out purporting to
be from Ukraine and they're actually old videos
from Russia that don't actually mean what it
seems. They mean we're trying to be careful
and report the things for which we have good
evidence to avoid confusing anybody and to avoid
creating more problems than than just informing
people. There is now widespread confirmation
that Vladimir Putin has put nuclear
forces on high alert. Now what that means
is subject to some debate, and we're going to talk
about that. But I'm going to make every effort to
give you all of the information we know to be
true, but no more than that so that people don't
end up confused. The Associated Press reporting
President Putin dramatically escalated East-West
tensions by ordering nuclear forces put on
high alert Sunday, while Ukraine's embattled
leader agreed to talks with Moscow as Putin's
troops and tanks drove deeper into the country,
closing in around the capital. Citing aggressive
statements by Naito and tough financial sanctions,
Putin issued a directive to increase the readiness
of Russia's nuclear weapons, raising fears that
the invasion of Ukraine could could lead to
nuclear war, whether by design or mistake. The
Russian leader is quote, potentially putting in
place forces that, if there's a miscalculation,
could make things much, much more dangerous, said
a senior U.S. official. Putin's directive came as
Russian forces encountered strong resistance from
Ukraine defenders. Moscow has so far failed to win
full control of Ukraine's airspace, despite
advances across the country. Another report
from CBS News Putin puts nuclear forces on alert
as fighting in Ukraine continues the way they
characterize it are. The move means Putin has
ordered Russia's nuclear weapons prepared for
increased readiness to launch, raising the threat
that tensions could boil over into a nuclear war.
So. Oh, and in the meantime, by the way, Belarus
preparing to join Russian invasion of Ukraine,
according to U.S. officials. And of course,
we should always have a healthy skepticism of
what intelligence agencies tell us on this
particular issue. They have been mostly right,
despite people saying, Oh, we can't believe
this, we can't trust this, it can't be trusted.
So that's the latest Belarus preparing to join. So
what are we to make of this? Well, first of all,
consider the contrast between first saying the
sanctions are toothless. We don't Putin. We don't
care about the sanctions, the sanctions don't.
Sanctions don't affect us next. Going to well,
we are potentially going to attack U.S. assets
as a result of the painful sanctions. Oh,
so the sanctions you said don't affect
you actually are painful all the way
up to. We are going to increase our state of
readiness when it comes to our nuclear arsenal.
As a result of those sanctions. Well, doesn't
sound like the sanctions are toothless,
if that's what you're willing to do. The other
aspect of this that I think is important is like
with everything else, we don't know what the point
of this is, is the point to actually get ready to
launch nukes. It's hard for me to believe that
because the truth is, the truth is, if you think
you might quote need to launch nukes or you think
that you might launch nukes for whatever reason,
you're always sort of at a state of readiness.
I mean, this is kind of the reality of how these
nations work and how these systems work. So the
announcement that you're increasing the state of
readiness is less about actually getting ready
to launch nukes. You would. Always be ready to
launch nukes, if that's what it came to and or
and to get to that state of readiness readiness
quickly. It's more about putting out there that
it's using the word nukes. That's really the big
thing here. And that's one perspective that this
is mostly meant to be a psychological escalation,
a rhetorical escalation rather than a real
one. The counterpoint to that is Putin
sort of seems like the type of kid that you know,
he poops in the sandbox when it's time to go home
because he doesn't want anyone else to be able
to play in it either. And that he genuinely,
particularly if he is in the altered state that
some are describing, might consider using nukes.